[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in dan shaughnessy boston
globe sports columnist
how big a deal is this with uh this
regular season match up brady coming to
town well dan it's a bigger deal than
you're making since you're going to the
cowboys opener if you're neutral
yeah but i'm a i'm let's say i'm not a
patriot fan or a brady fan
that's the season opener pomp and
circumstance you got
you know you've got concerts you've got
all kinds of things
yeah i hear that and again i don't
consider myself particularly provincial
but this thing
there's so much pathos here so much you
know history buildup as you say it's
personal
uh it's epic i mean you know you got
there's going to be arguments for both
of these to be the greatest ever what
they did
and they were together 20 years they
went to nine super bowls they won
six of them i mean yeah the notion of
him coming in there
after winning the super bowl after
leaving with hard feelings
in foxborough with bob crap there
schmoozing on the sideline
and and all the anger you know the anger
we have here in new england with the
patriot fans
it'll be a rare night though dan they'll
be chair no matter what because they
they love the patriots and they love tom
brady
so there's going to be a lot of cheering
every time either one scores
but we wondered yesterday if
before the game brady gets it out of the
way and acknowledges
bill or vice versa because you know
robert kraft is going to be on the
sidelines and he's going to be hugging
tom
oh yeah but kissing him okay but but
what happens with brady and belichick
either before or after the game there
might be a ceremonial thing not not much
more than that
and i mean tom's kind of rubbed his face
and he's been talking about it a year
how much fun this is he gets to be the
general manager he gets alex guerrero
back he'll have guerrero on a throne on
the sideline
you know all the hard feelings all the
things that went on here you know bill's
saying you know he didn't exactly have
heart surgery when he came back and
played with a cut hand
and just a little little subtle shots
and then and bill's going to be as soon
as that game's over bill's going to be
we're on to houston you know he will not
talk about
the emotion of coaching against tom if
you said to belichick you can schedule
this game or not have this game
like it would be his decision do you
think the fact that you're hosting brady
do you think that he would want this i
think he'd rather not because of all the
the circus and the noise
the five months of build up the ticket
prices and the questions he hates that
he hates all the ancillary stuff if you
want to talk to him
ask about the army navy game he'll talk
to you about that all day
he doesn't want to talk about the
emotion of coaching against tom brady
do you think he cared if brady won the
super bowl
yes yes i think legacies are important
to all these guys and i think that
uh it's it in a way it made people that
aren't paying close attention say well
it was brady all along
there you go now we know and nobody
wants to hear that when you have his
track record and he knows it's a stupid
theory
it's a stupid takeaway but casual people
that love tom it's like well
evidently it was all it was all the
quarterback the whole time which of
course is ridiculous
when the patriots were in the super bowl
against the eagles and i did an
interview with tom a couple of days
prior
and i said when this is all done do you
think you and bill will ever sit down
and like open up the scrapbook and he
looked at me like that's
the craziest question you can he goes
no and i went like there wasn't
anything further it was like no
no that's i believe that to be true i
think he's telling you the truth there i
think it was a great professional
relationship
with a lot of mutual respect i think
they grew apart
as more and more people were poking
about who's getting the credit who's
getting the blame
and uh and there were subtle shots all
the time i referenced that thing about
brady had his hand cut open the week of
the playoff game
and then got stitched up the day before
and there was all this noise about oh
tom what a warrior how could he have
done that and bill says
it's not like he had open heart surgery
there were always little shots like that
and then tom's been doing it like the
whole time since he left
about how oh it's fun here come on down
it's fun
they let you do what you want you don't
have to go through all this misery all
this misery of
of winning that they did for 20 years
anyway yeah it's very real i believe oh
my god
it's not like he had open-heart surgery
[Laughter]
if i would have given you garoppolo or
mac jones last month
that's a tough one i'm kind of in on
garoppolo and there's no learning curve
there he knows the system
you wouldn't have to be looking at cam
newton's cam newton's going to be the
quarterback at the start of the season
and that's going to cause another
a lot more noise here which bill hates
like when are you going to go to the kid
if things don't get off quickly if you
gave it to garoppolo you wouldn't have
that he knows the system you could put
him in there bill hates rookie
quarterbacks there's going to be a
learning curve for joe no matter what
but you don't know what the future the
kid's going to be and i
the good chance that the next 10 years
of
of the kid is better than the next 10
years of garoppolo
yeah i was just curious and then you you
draft a brady
clone yep you know a quarterback who's
embraced
the comparison to tom brady so i don't
know
if he's like is he afraid of the big
spotlight here doesn't seem like it
i don't think i don't think the
quarterback is at all yeah but bill is
afraid of putting a ricky quarterback
into the into the fire
right out of the gate because because he
has taken advantage of ricky
quarterbacks for 20 years
but he loves to play against him so you
if you were a betting man
of does mac jones play at all this year
yes i think he plays but i think it's
going to be i mean it depends on how bad
cam is of course
the big issue is going to be if cams bad
out of the gate they get off one and
three two and two whatever
and there's all this pressure to let the
kid play bill hates to cave into that
but i think by the end of the year i
think that the idea is to transition
to jones for next year so yeah you
probably want to look at them at the end
but it depends on what's at stake where
they are in playoff positioning
all that sort of thing uh before i let
you go the state of the celtics here
oh boy it's funny you say that i've got
a calling with danny ainge i'm talking
to you instead of talking to danny ainge
right now because
it's bad here dan and um there are 500
team which is unbelievable after 70
games
they have two left they're going to be
the seventh seed and they're gonna have
to do the playing round
this team was in the finals of the
conference three of the last four years
they have two all-stars in brown and
tatum and there's excuses with cobia and
injuries but overall
it's been a very underachieving team
that has been unlikable
they get way behind in games then they
ratchet up their defense their shots
start falling they play hard
very annoying team very unceltic like
not characteristic of what folks around
here
embrace and uh they're behind the eight
ball because they've been fat and happy
for a lot of years
but brad stevens this is eight years in
yeah and we're not seeing it's going the
wrong way
are you going to the basketball hall of
fame induction ceremony
that's i wish i was the answer is no
that's a great event
do you have a favorite story of any of
those players
with uh kobe or duncan garnett
well i mean i mean the favorite story of
course is
is is duncan rick pitino came here
assuming he was getting duncan what was
he thinking
i mean rick pitino left a really good
situation
came in here took red's name off the
masthead and you know had it all teed up
for tim duncan and he ends up with with
mercer and phillips so he traded in a
month
i mean he got three and six instead of
one it was
it was franchise altering for the next
25 years so that's my tim duncan story
if duncan had gone to the celtics
finish that statement i think that that
patino has a
much longer career here and and i think
that
you know pierce would have come in they
would have been good
they would have been good in the early
part of the century you know instead of
really bad
and and finding their way to 2008 of
course garnett comes in and rescues him
but
the years between 96 and 2008 would have
been far more pleasant around here in
basketball is
is ange given enough credit to pull off
the trade to bring in garnett
that unlike red arbok would do that all
the time it felt like
but you know danny was so his former
teammate kevin mchale is there and
they're
they're basically saying here danny take
a future hall of famer and go win a
championship
well it has the as the appearance of a
bag job and when i was a young guy
covering that team
when danny and kevin and larry were
teammates they would play cards and red
would go by and say danny isn't that
against your religion you can't play
cards with those guys
and danny would point to to larry and
kevin say red it's not gambling against
these guys
and lo and behold 20 years go by and
kevin mchale
gives him kevin garnett gives him a
championship so
yeah that one should have been
investigated uh i'll i'll let you get
your phone call with danny ainge good
luck with that dan thanks for joining us
we appreciate it
thanks dan that's stan shaughnessy
boston globe